une plus récemment la grippe de hong
kong que je cite aussi dans cet article
entre 68 et 70 ans certainement on
discutera les chiffres enfin c'est des
chiffres
ils ont donc dans de grandeur comparable
locaux vides et à l'époque aussi les
zones le pito était totalement saturé
en france on en parlait c'était en page
5 des journaux les gens mettaient des
masques dans certains endroits mais ça
faisait partie civile et des aléas de la
vie
une société savait digérer parce que
c'était une société qui pensaient
surtout à vivre et combien pensez tel
aviv re puisqu'on est en plein en pleine
période 68 qu'on aura woodstock les
monts libre et que mes parents que je
souhaite protéger aujourd'hui n'ont même
pas le souvenir parce que on a parlé à
peine et effectivement on pourrait en
mourir comme aujourd'hui des jeunes
peuvent aussi mourir des très jeunes
peuvent mourir d'un cancer d'un avc d'un
infarctus et donc le risque existait et
on vivait avec le risque et je pense que
on vivait mieux quelque part en ayant
pris en compte ce risque
ça c'est vraiment ce que dit montagne
ont joui mieux de la vie quand on sait
que la mort peut frapper et aujourd'hui
c'est un peu l'inversé
à force de vouloir se protéger
absolument de la mort ont fini par
cesser de vivre en tant qu'humanité on
peut pas continuer à survivre en
cherchant à éliminer totalement le
risque c'est juste impossible et donc il
va falloir admettre que l'on fasse la
fête qu on danse on a eu un débat en
prônant oui en prenant des risques a pas
forcément aujourd'hui maintenant encore
une fois ces mesures peuvent se
justifier mais de manière plus générale
ne pas prendre l'habitude de vivre dans
un univers totalement aseptisé où on ne
craint rien mais où du coup on n'espère
rien non plus
[Musique]